on vient maintenant cette information
qui nous est parvenue à quelques
instants du crâne la région de Donia
est-ce qu'au moins 16 personnes ont été
tuées dans une attaque russe Gulliver
crack vous êtes à Kiev pour France 24
que c'est ton plus sur cette frappe qui
a coûté la vie je le rappelle et je le
redis une nouvelle fois au moins 16
personnes
oui
une ville contre les par l'Ukraine à
l'ouest de backmouth entre une
demi-heure et une heure de route de bac
mouton normal avant que Batman ne soit
occupé par les Russes c'est donc non
loin de la ligne de front mais c'est une
zone absolument civile qui a été frappée
à marcher malheureusement ce bilan de 16
mots va très probablement augmenter
puisque c'est le centre-ville et un
endroit où beaucoup de personnes étaient
en train de faire leurs courses le
Premier ministre
ukrainien et le président volody
mirzelinski ont déjà écrit sur cet
événement sur les réseaux sociaux
volodime of Zelenski disons que cela
devrait servir de rappel à quiconque
voudrait négocier avec la Russie
voudrait penser que c'est possible de
obtenir une accord avec la Russie un
rappel de quel genre de régime à quoi on
a vraiment à faire c'est ce que vous le
dit a écrit sur Instagram je perds
évidemment mais il semblerait vraiment
que ce soit une attaque très très
meurtrière et c'est le centre-ville
absolument de cette ville Constantine
IFCA qui tout en étant non loin de la
ligne de France était tout de même une
ville où la vie continue plus ou moins
avec avec son son train normal si on
peut parler d'un train normal de vie
dans n'importe quelle ville du don-basse
Merci à VOUS Gulliver Gulliver Craig